it's official perks is moving to c9
this is a player so popular that when he
moved
from g2's mid lane to their ad carry
position
it was one of the biggest pieces of news
in lec
history and this blows that out of the
water
seriously unless faker like moves to na
next week
this is definitely going to be the
biggest move of the off season
all right guys before we get into all
this off-season craziness
i'm gonna ask you to make sure you are
subscribed also
let us know in the comments what kinds
of videos you want to see next on the
channel
and if you have any really good
suggestions for videos you can always
email them to us at tips the score dot
com
when i first heard the news reported by
jacob wolfe i
immediately thought that this has the
potential to be
the biggest euna transfer story in
league's history but i do get a little
bit carried away sometimes
so we sat down with lcs caster azale to
get some
level-headed confirmation i mean i
definitely think it's the biggest
transfer to have ever happened you know
as far as uh
in in the western scene from europe to
na because this is a player that's
absolutely at his prime who is you know
one of the best if not the best all-time
players from the lac
we always hear a lot of crazy stuff
right before the free agent
period starts and perks moving to n a
just sounded like another one of those
wishful transactions
i mean he literally said in a tweet last
year
that he was never going to move to na
and why would he everyone believed him
just
five months after that tweet he helped
g2 reach their first ever worlds finals
okay they then lost pretty convincingly
to a rampaging firm plus phoenix but the
point is they had shown
they had something that most western
teams only
dream of the ability to compete
internationally
that is why it was so shocking when
wolff dropped the news on twitter last
thursday that cloud9
had made a verbal agreement to take on
perks as their new mid laner
the community was rocked by the news and
pretty soon we had a whole load of
questions how much
was the deal worth how long was it gonna
be for
once again jacob wolf had all the
answers on the free agency talk show
i think the buyout is probably gonna be
somewhere in the
two to three million dollar range i
think that
the salary is going to be somewhere in
the two to
two to three million dollar range
annually so and i think it will be a
long term deal
somewhere between two or three years so
we're probably looking at something that
will be close to if i had to guess
and total deal value probably something
just shy of 9 million
for 3 years now as a fan of any esport
you should always expect change
it happens but that doesn't always mean
it's pretty
after the news dropped some people
speculated that perks actually wanted to
play for
fnatic but g2's owner carlos had blocked
that move
to stop his main competition from
getting stronger this
is something that carlos clapped back at
on twitter by saying that perks is one
of his closest
friends that he would never [ __ ] him
over for a game
and that he's his son's favorite uncle
very sweet
perks echoed that sentiment and asked
everyone to stop
the hate towards g2 and carlos and that
he was grateful for
everything they had given him now that
the dust has begun to settle and the
shock anger and elation on both sides of
the atlantic has begun to subside
what does perk signing for c9 actually
mean for the future
tim 7 houston spoke on the free agency
show about the
huge expectations that now lie on c9
after this move there's a big story to
tell about what kind of expectations
they built for themselves i think if
cloud9 makes this acquisition
and comes in and doesn't win lcs and
doesn't at least get out of groups of
worlds or you know
probably be expected to do a little
better than that then to me i think you
have to question you know
is is it really worth that kind of
resource layout then there's
n a as a region some people have said
that one of the main reasons
n a seems to falter internationally is
its tendency to sign
big name imports at the expense of
fostering local talent
there's nothing inherently wrong with
importing talent i think that the
problem comes when you
invest in importing at the expense of
you know focusing on your own regional
talent
so maybe there is nothing to fear
especially with a team like
c9 they above all others have shown that
they
understand the importance of grassroots
homegrown
talent after all they were the ones that
took a team of three rookies and a
handful of veterans all the way to world
semi-finals in 2018
the single best result for n a in modern
league history
perks could be the veteran catalyst that
c9
builds their team around he'll be
reuniting with former teammate zven
he'll be joining forces with the likes
of blabber and vulcan and he'll be
fighting alongside an lcs rookie
in the form of fudge this mix of
experience and new blood
could be the key to unlocking c9 and
na's potential
and i do think that perks is one of the
best western players of all time i mean
he has absolutely dominated europe for
so many years
uh he has had some of the most
incredible international runs he's an
msi champion he's made the finals of
worlds
perks is one of those guys that is
a competitor forever every single skill
that is developed
on perks is directly related to the game
is directly related to
his impact on the team in the game and
while we're seeing perks grow off air
and while we see perks grow
in the social media spotlight and learn
how to handle that pressure
it's also complementing his game now
generally speaking
i would say n a fans are pretty hype
about seeing such a big talent
come to na and eu fans are rolling their
eyes in disappointment
for them it's a pretty long running meme
the n a
is just a retirement home for eu players
and that perks is just the latest victim
of this talent drain
that said perks is far from retirement
as we all know
he will probably find a good home so
don't worry about him he will
he will he'll be fine with his new with
his new teammates new york
there is no uh there's no sadness i mean
of course it would be fun to
to have the last dance along perks in uh
2021 you know us five or something but
yeah nothing can last forever for a zale
perks could turn n a
into a dream or let it remain as an
international meme
you know if perks does really well in in
north america and if they get
international success i think that
you know is encouraging to more european
stars to maybe make the move because if
you can kind of have it all right if you
can have the international success in
north america and also have a bigger
salary
then why wouldn't you want to come here
i think if on on the other side
if park student fails in north america
if they don't do well internationally or
even you know
fail to qualify for international play
then that kind of reinforces i think
some of
the stereotypes of like okay if you go
to ma you can't have that success you
can't
you know reach the same heights that you
can in europe so perks is likely to be
the biggest move of the offseason but
there are so
many other moves that we haven't talked
about tsm hoonie
who saw that coming so tsm are
finalizing a buyout agreement with evil
geniuses for top laner hoonie huni
tsm are also looking to pick up sword
art they have just got themselves
a fresh world finalist if that report is
true
team liquid alfari and santorin 100
thieves grabbing closer
fbi and huhi and flyquest acquiring
licorice and jose diodo who is only the
second
ever south american import to the lcs
over in europe we see nisky going to
fnatic
we see broken blade going to schalke and
of course
there's a huge question mark over who
will fill perks's role
as g2's ad carry and at the moment it
looks like it's going to be
reckless crazy he's been a fanatic
icon for so many years and now it looks
like he's joining their biggest rival
how will g2 do with him on the team
there is still
so much to discuss but for now perks is
still
the biggest headline i am so excited to
see
how this move turns out not just for
perks but for c9
for n a for eu and maybe this will
shake things up at worlds next year yes
that is right i'm already talking about
worlds
and it's less than a month since the
last one ended
the hype starts now so this video has
been
all about one player but like there's so
many other players
that i want to talk about um one in
particular would be
tsm hooning i don't know how to feel
about that
i'm like i'm pretty confused it could go
really really well or it could go
horribly
wrong and i'd say as a tsm fan
that pretty much sums up tsm doesn't it